i remember the first time i ever did
cocaine i was in new orleans and uh and
my buddy
had a rock
and he had a screen of a damn this makes
me want to touch my [ __ ] dick even
hearing about it he told me one of my
best friends to this day one of my best
friends and uh he said i we were looking
for uh ecstasy
and he said i don't have any ecstasy and
i said you're partying right he was like
i am we're same age uh
and he goes i and what do you look like
a white guy
a really good looking guy
more italian more looking like
michelangelo
um
you know you know michelangelo's name
wasn't michael angelo
it was in one word there's one word and
it was and that was part of a bigger
name i thought it was michael angelo not
like michelangelo pizzeria
mussolini that's a black italian i think
if it's the full one yeah
it's amazing there aren't more
michelangelo's anyway
he he said i have cocaine and i said i
said you i remember going you do you do
cocaine and he goes i yeah we do cocaine
he was like and i was like
is it safe and he was like yeah it's
totally safe he goes here's the deal
look me in the eyes and he said
it's really good
and it could become a problem and he
goes in it it has for friends like
trust me
and i was like what should i do and he
goes he goes on you got to make that
decision on your own so i went to my
buddy who i was looking for xc with and
i said we can't get xc but we can get
cocaine and he was like he's like i'll
do it i was like i was like i've never
done it he goes it's pretty good and i
was like really and he was like yeah
so we went back i said i'll do some
didn't have to buy it he just gave us
you know i grew up with a kid and he
shaved it off of the screen of like a
window it was a screen it was a screen
that was on like a a tilt so it was like
two sticks with a screen that went like
this it was maybe this big that's
carpenter's cut dude and that [ __ ] is
good he shaved it off of that and it
feathered down
and he cut a line and uh
he said snort half of that
with one with your nose and i smooth the
whole thing with one nostril and he goes
that that's
i think you're good and i went okay
and theo immediately from this tooth
over and this tooth over went ice numb
the whole side of my face and i went
i was like whoo i thought
and my first thought was
i i
remember i could walk outside and rip a
tree out of the ground
and carry it around tonight
but i'm so smart that i won't do that
because if they see me with the tree
they'll go he's on cocaine
so i'm not ripping trees out and then i
was like i think i'm going to need to do
the other nose because this side isn't
numb and he was like okay just a little
one
and he gave me another line and i did
the other side and this tooth went sing
i mean i could hear it go see
and it went all the way over there and i
said uh i looked at my buddy
and that my oh i won't say his name the
buddy i was partying with ron and close
and so i said to our other friend i
think i think we're gonna go down to the
bourbon street and he's like okay he's
like he's like no cell phones he's like
we'll see you later and i was like great
and i looked at my buddy and i said
let's go have some fun
we took a little bit of pouch with us
and we had one of the most exciting
nights of our lives and and
and maybe i don't even think we did any
more cocaine throughout the night i
think we maybe did a key bump maybe yeah
but i don't think we did anymore and we
had the greatest [ __ ] night of our
life and then that night went back
passed out my truck
woke up when the sun was coming up with
the most acutely searing anxiety attack
i've ever had in my life and we had an
eight ball left that my buddy gave me
for to take home and and we had to drive
you to take home yeah yeah and so i took
the eight ball i put it in my cherokee
we drove from new orleans to tallahassee
and all my brain did was like
i heard my brain you know you got
regular brain where you go
hey maybe we should pull over and get
mcdonald's and your little regular brain
regular little guy you've been with your
whole life and then you go well that
sounds like a good idea and he's like i
just thought i'd put it right up bring
it up yeah and so i get in the car and
little brain's like dude we still have
that cocaine right and i was like yeah i
put it in the it's in the middle he's
like are you sure that's a good idea and
then all of a sudden this this [ __ ]
anxiety voice goes
what the [ __ ] are we traveling with
cocaine dude we're going to [ __ ] jail
what the [ __ ] you need to pull over
right now you need to hide that in one
of your bags either that or do it we
gotta do cocaine that'll make the drive
so much better and i was like should we
get food and he's like [ __ ] that we've
got iron stomach
we can't get our dick card and we can't
[ __ ] let's drive drive it was like sam
sam kittison was in my head and then i i
tell you very candidly i haven't got rid
of that voice forever that's why i don't
[ __ ] around cocaine is that [ __ ]
voice the next day all that fun that was
it's not worth it to hear that guy yeah
just dude we better get out of bed
you're on blood pressure medicine what
the [ __ ] did we do last night
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you